aux bleus
respect pour respecter quand tu lis on
arrive à tout gérer un de perdu mais
à ces recours et a besoin d'un homme qui
l'empêchent d'avancer est là c est sa
fierté c'est pas elle que du vert amande
série brothers ou par marie ça change en
rien sa façon de pensée forte de ferrer
ses dires de l qui j'avais son dernier
mot et w gear faisait pour bien des
dérives
elle est le copain lui
les airs
mou rêve à tout assumer tu connais la
richesse de domérat tout a subi mais
voit toujours famille ta peau
va-tout d'assumer genre de pièges et
problèmes sens aux airs touda super
milos aller
à lire
m
allez hop
qu'assumer super
mais
et de deux
fois où elle aurait une autre
qu'elle pouvait y arriver
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime bien